[Music]
i am latin so i get to feel whatever i
want i always wanted a daughter to dress
her up in pretty dresses to her hair her
nails her makeup
no one knows this but for the first year
of his life i made up money like a girl
and told everybody that he was my
daughter
i've adjusted a few times i didn't want
to mess with his head
when he found the pictures i told him
that it was his twin sister who died
is something wrong who's died noah manny
why would you even think that in
colombia manny went to pablo escobar
elementary school if you were pulled out
of class it was definitely to identify a
body well we got your poncho here i
thought he said it made me look like my
neck was wearing a dress that was a joke
oh good it's still in the pocket what do
you got there buddy my pan flute i'm
going to play some colombian folk music
for my new classmates huh great
i've never been more proud of you i'm
sure your friends are gonna love it
break the flute what the poncho by
itself is fine the poncho plus the flute
plus the stupid dance my son will die a
virgin
that's right
hey sport can i take a look at that
whistle
oh jeez look at that and now you stepped
on it what a
darn what's wrong with me
i am a very lucky woman i have a
wonderful family a beautiful home
there's nothing that i would change
i hate the dog butler
i keep forgetting it's there and every
time it happens it scares me all over
again
sometimes at night
i think it's the devil
are you gonna go to church next week
we'll see i know what we'll see means if
you're done with church just say it i'm
done with church
tell me the truth jay did you put the
key in my bag
no i won't be mad
in order to prove a point i may
why did i get you such a big watch yj
what point do you have to prove i'm
trying to teach you to be organized your
mind is scattered gloria your mind is
going to be scattered manny hamid
uh alex why do you have a medical form
with my name on it
i don't think i should be the one to
explain this
manny
as you know your mother and jorge had a
relationship
you're a lot alike and it made us
curious as to whether
uh are are you saying this is a dna test
your mom didn't even find out until
today
um
i
i don't even know how to react
so my whole childhood was a lie i
thought javier was my dad now he's just
some stranger who gave me baths listen
buddy
it's not who brings you into the world
it's what you do when you're there
you're not javier you're not this guy
you're you and what you are is amazing
and for the record i've been your dad
since you're 10 and i'm gonna be your
dad until i'm gone
i love you and i always will
i love you too jay
[Laughter]
april fools
now who doesn't understand a joke what
i never dated jorge he's the butcher at
the grocery store i just thought that he
looked like manny
why would you do that
because you said that i didn't
understand funny
i didn't know you were going to take the
prank this far you made grandpa cry i
know he was like
[Laughter]
[Music]
it no more singing
why
because you stink
you're a terrible singer
come on let's get some lunch
how dare do you tell me that no no no no
no fighting in front of the baby we just
made a deal yeah but that's so fair
because i am always in front of the baby
gloria you're as close to perfect as a
woman gets nothing wrong with one tiny
little flaw yours is when you start to
sing
it sounds like something got stuck in
the vacuum cleaner that's your job god
that is just your stupid stupid opinion
jay
but i am very angry at you and i am
gonna make a list of all the things that
i am going to scream at you as soon as
this baby is out of me
dr donna and gloria were like two
assassins just picking off their victims
one by one
[Music]
okay last two dodgeballers are you ready
yes
are you ready
yes
oh i'm so sorry i'm going to kill you
what's all that about
you mad at me or something i don't know
did you do something to make me mad
because then i am but if you didn't then
i am not i didn't do anything then i am
not mad i am mad last night jay had a
sexy dream about some woman
oh
baby
oh
oh baby
oh baby
[Music]
and i know it wasn't about me because he
knows that i hate when men call me baby
and yes people are allowed their private
thoughts and i shouldn't be so angry
but i am lacking so i get to feel
whatever i want that's so sad i live
with four teenagers you live with two
adults no no it's so sad that you come
here so often and that's the best that
you can shoot oh
and that's with pretty nails
manny it's okay over there on the bike
the white guy that stole my phone i
don't see anyone yes he just turned the
corner the phone burglar he's getting
away
not this time
to the left
[Music]
i don't see anyone i didn't see anyone
either i made it up i am not going to
drive my son around until he's 40.
the only thing stronger than manny's
fear is his need to protect his mama
my mom doesn't believe that principal
brown likes me can you tell her
gloria
my phone english not so good i am so
sick of stubborn you you act like a
little boy that doesn't want to accept
that he's wrong and you like a sad old
man that doesn't want to be happy that's
it
you could have shot me come on manny i
could have unbought on your shirt if i
wanted to now come here or sink
and i'm taking this with me in the car
oh
hey honey surprise i'm in san francisco
what i drove mania to friends and things
was crazy but i hopped on a plane and
i'm here i'm driving to the hotel that
is so great
the thing is honey i'm not here right
now see i'm uh
i'm out of dinner
probably won't be back for um
oh a couple hours it's okay i'll wait
for you there
don't be silly how often do you get to
san francisco there's so much to see
there
i mean here
gia deli square fisherman's wharf
alcatraz hey take that segway tour
that's a great way to see the city and
when you get the chowder make sure it's
in one of those bread bowls you can eat
the bowl yeah it's a story you'll tell
for a lifetime
i am not mad at you because you told me
that i snore i am mad at you because you
didn't say anything because i didn't
want to get yelled at well too bad when
you're married to me you're going to get
jailed up many times
you're tough enough to take it
that's what i love about our marriage we
can say whatever we want but the next
day we're still there that's what i like
about it too
ah what am i gonna say you couldn't
forgive me there are things jay
you ready to go i was thinking it's such
a shame that this hotel room is going to
go to waste i like where this is headed
make money some pasta i'll see you
tomorrow morning okay
[Music]
you